[Music]
today
we're going to start a very important
and interesting topic of mathematics
called integrals we have already learnt
about
derivatives and also understood how to
find the derivative of
any given function so let me ask you
this
what is the derivative of the function
sine x
yes it's cos x here
the derivative of the function sine x is
well defined
and it's given by cos x
now suppose that we're given the
derivative but not the function
so can we find the function using its
derivative
yes we can and this is what we're going
to learn in this series
based on integrals now
coming back to our example we have cos x
as the derivative of sine x
so can you tell me what this sine x is
called with respect to its derivative
well this sine x is called the
antiderivative of cos
x so in order to find the function we
need to find the anti-derivative of its
given derivative
and this anti-derivative will be our
required function
this process of finding anti-derivatives
is called
integration integration is an important
part of the calculus
it is used not only to find a function
whenever its derivative
is given but also to find the area
bounded by the graph of a function
under certain conditions these two uses
lead to the two forms of the integrals
indefinite
and definite which together constitute
the integral calculus
integration is used to solve many
interesting problems
from various disciplines like economics
finance probability and so on
but for the time being we will confine
ourselves to the study of
indefinite and definite integrals and
their elementary properties
including some techniques of integration
so in the next video we will understand
this process of
integration in more detail
thank you for watching this video i'll
see you
in the next one